[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور من مدينه رام الله
في الضفه الغربيه وهناك تصعيد اسرائيلي
واقتحامات للمستوطنين في مدن
عده ومن حلب نرصد هذه الصور بعد قصف شهدته
اليوم من قبل قوات النظام السوري على قرى
ريف
المحافظه وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه
الليله غدات اقتحام المستوطنين لبلده
حواره جنوبيه نابلس بحمايه جيش الاحتلال
مشهد تصعيد اسرائيلي يتسع واكثر من 80
مصابا في مواجهات مع الجيش الاسرائيلي في
البلده والاتحاد الاوروبي يعرب عن قلقه
ويطالب بضمان المسائله وحمايه
[تصفيق]
المدنيين اثناء احتفالات في ذكرى تاسيس
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي امن السلطه
الفلسطينيه يقتحم مخيم نور شمس بطول كرم
ومخيم جنين ويشتبك مع مقاومين والامين
العام للحركه يقول ان اجهزه امن السلطه
تلاحق وتعتقل الفلسطينيين بقرار امريكي
اسرائيلي قتل وجرحى في قصف للنظام السوري
على مناطق في ريفي ادلب وحلب الدفاع
المدني شمالي البلاد يعلن تعرض منطقه جسر
الشغور لقصف بقنابل محرمه دوليا وفي الشرق
السوري تركيا تؤكد مواصله عملياتها ضد
المواقع الكرديه وتطالب واشنطن بوقف دعمها
للمسلحين
الاكراد
غداه تحذير اوروبي من فجوه في المساعدات
الامريكيه لاوكرانيا تنعكس على الدعم
العسكري واشنطن تتجه لاستخدام برامج منح
تابعه للخارجيه بعيدا عن الكونجرس وقلق
اوروبي ازاء خطوه روسيا لانشاء قاعده
بحريه دائمه في منطقه ابخازيا الانفصاليه
في
جورجيا في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرقميه ناقشنا احتجاج بولندا
والمج خلال قمه الدول ال 27 في اسبانيا
اليوم على اصلاح نظام الهجره الاوروبي هذا
الاحتجاج بعد يومين من التوصل الى اتفاق
يعد اساسيا بين الدول الاعضاء لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي ما هي تداعيات هذه
الخلافات على التكتل الاوروبي وتعامله مع
ملف طالب اللجوء
43% اشاروا الى طغيان الحلول والسياسات
الفرديه
57% قالوا ان الامور ستتجه الى مزيد من
التشدد في قوانين تنظيم الهجره هذا السؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم
دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار
الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا
ودوليا وتبعونا في الحصاد ايضا برنامج
متحري يكشف خفايا اختفاء الالاف من اطفال
اليهود اليمنيين بعد وصولهم الى اسرائيل
قبل
[موسيقى]
عقود اعلن الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني اصابه
78 فلسطينيا بينهم اثنان اصيب بالرصاص
الحي خلال المواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في بلده حواره جنوب نابلس
وافادت مراسلتنا ان عشرات المواطنين
اصيبوا بحالات اختناق جراء اطلاق قوات
الاحتلال قنابل الغاز لقمع الشبان
المتظاهرين هذا ودان منسق الامم المتحده
لعمليه السلام في الشرق الاوسط اعتداء
المستوطنين على الفلسطينيين وممتلكاتهم في
حواره ودعى اسرائيل الى ضمان سلامه
المدنيين ومعاقبه الجنه من جانبه اعرب
الاتحاد الاوروبي عن قلقه البالغ اذاء
ارتفاع مستوى العنف في بلده حواره في
الغربيه ودعى عبر منصه اكس الى ضمان
المسائله وحمايه
المدنيين حواره تعتبر من اكثر نقاط التماس
سخونه بين الفلسطينيين والمستوطنين في
الضفه الغربيه اذ تقع البلده على الطريق
الرئيسي الذي يسلكه جميع المستوطنين
القاطنين في المستوطنات المقامه شمال
الضفه
المحتله حواره او الارض البيضاء لا يذكر
اسم حواره الا ويستحضر الفلسطينيون معركه
العلم بين اهل البلده والمستوطنين حوار
واحده من 56 قريه وبلده تتبع نابلس احدى
اكبر محافظات شمال الضفه الغربيه حسب
اتفاق اوسلو صنفت اراضي حواره بين مناطق
باه الخاضعه اداريا وامنيا للسلطه
الفلسطينيه ومنطقه جيم الخاضعه للسيطره
العسكريه الاسرائيليه لا تزيد مساحه حواره
عن 100 الا دنم يعيش فيها 7000 فلسطيني
رغم ذلك اقتطعت اسرائيل من اراضي حواره
اكثر من 3000 دنم لاقامه مستوطنتي جفعات
رونين ويتس هار التي تقطنها اكثر جماعات
المستوطنين تطرفا والمعروفه
[موسيقى]
بشبيبة لا تهدا بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه
والمستوطنين وجنود الاحتلال وقد حول
الاحتلال حواره الى ثكنه عسكريه باقامه 15
برجا عسكريا ونشر عشرات الحواجز المتحركه
على طول الطريق الرئيسي للبلده كما شرعت
السلطات الاسرائيليه في شق طريق التفافي
بديل عن طريق حوار الرئيسي حيث صادر
الاحتلال اكثر من 400 دنم من اراضي بلدات
حوارا وبيتا وعورت لشق الطريق الالتفافي
الذي سيخصص فقط لمركبات الجيش والمستوطنين
منعا لاي احتكاك مع
الفلسطينيين في الساس والعش من فبراير
الماضي شهدت حواره احدى اكثر عمليات
المقاومه جراه حين باغت عبد الفتاح خروشه
سياره مستوطنين تعبر طريق حوار الرئيسي
فقتل اثنين منهم بعد هذه العمليه تحولت
حواره الى بؤره لعمليات المقاومه وفي
الوقت ذاته الى هدف لعمليات انتقاميه
للمستوطنين اعتى هجمات المستوطنين كانت
اواخر فبراير الماضي على بلدتي زعتره
وحواره واسفرت عن استشهاد فلسطيني وجرح
390 كما احرقوا 80 منزلا واكثر من 100
سياره مدنيه تتكرر هذه الهجمات عقب كل
عمليه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه اذ تنطلق جموع
المستوطنين من مستوطنات يتسهار وجعات
رونين وهار راخا ليعيثوا خرابا في حواره
حرقا وتنكيلا يحدث ذلك بغطاء ومباركه من
حكومه الاحتلال اليمنيه يدعو وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي بت سليل سموتريتش الى تغيير
التعامل الامني مع الاحداث في الضفه يطالب
الحكومه بقبده اكثر شده على الفلسطينيين
هناك يترافق ذلك مع مشروع يعمل عليه وزير
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي تمار بنفير
لتسليح جميع الاسرائيليين وفرض قيود على
حركه الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه منعا
لاي هجمات على
المستوطنين اقتحمت قوه من جيش الاحتلال
بلده الخضر جنوب بيت اللحم بالضفه الغربيه
واظهرت صور مركبات عسكريه اسرائليه تحاصر
احد المنازل هناك وافادت مصادر محليه
باندلاع مواجهات بين شبان فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال
ينضم الينا من الناصره محمد زيدان الباحث
المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه سيد زيدان
يعني ما الغرض من اطلاق يد المستوطنين في
هذه الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه يعني لا شك بان حواره منذ
شباط الماضي تحولت الى نقطه احتكاك
المستوطنون يستغلون كافه الامكانيات لفرض
امر
واقع عمليا يتحكمون في مداخل القريه وكل
من يخرج منها هذا بالاضافه الى التواجد
العسكري الموجود حاليا حركه الاستيطان او
الصهيونيه الدينيه المتمثله بالمجموعات
الاستيطانيه ترى بان هناك فرصه تاريخيه
امامها من اجل فرض اجندتها وفرض برنامجها
السياسي عمليا هذه المجموعات لم تعد في
هامش السياسه الاسرائيليه وانما اصبحت هي
من يقرر
عمليا في الحكومه وبالتالي وهم يشعرون
بهذه القوه بان الحكومه معتمده على وجودهم
ويهددون بتركها في كل لحظه ويشكلون ضغطا
على قيادتها في الليكود والليكود من جهته
وبنيامين نتنياهو الذي يعني يحاول قدر
الامكان امساك العصا من الطرفين يعني
نتنياهو يريد من جهه ان يبقي هذه
المجموعات المتطرفه معه
للابقاء على حكومته ولكن من جهه اخرى هو
يستمع ل ما يقوله القيادات السيا العسكريه
والامنيه الاسرائيليه التي ليس لها مصلحه
في هذا التصعيد وتحاول ان تبقي الامر على
ما هو جاري منذ اكثر من عام لماذا ليس لها
مح هذا تحيد تصعيد يعني عند الحديث عن
تباين في وجهات النظر الاسرائيليه بين
اليمنيين والمتدينين والخ
مثل القيادات العسكريه او قوى علمانيه
اخرى ما المبرر للاختلاف اصلا
يعني ال القيادات الامنيه الاسرائيليه ليس
يعني من اجل مصلحه الفلسطينيين ولكن من
اجل رؤيتها لما هو مصلحه اسرائيل القيادات
العسكريه والامنيه تريد ان تبقي ان تقوم
بعمليات محدده محسوبه النتائج يمكنها ان
يعني ان تسيطر على ارتفاع اللهب ولا تفلت
الامور بعد الاقتحام الاخير لمخيم جنين
كان هناك قرار بانه الاستمرار في عمليات
عينيه محدده وهذا ما يتم عمليا بشكل يومي
في الضفه الغربيه المحتله اعتقالات
اقتحامات اغتيالات يوميه هم يريدون
الاستمرار بذلك دون العوده الى نمط يمكن
ان يكون مشابه لما حصل في جنين والذي يمكن
ان يجر الى ردود فعل ايضا في القدس وحتى
في الداخل او من غزه واطلاق صواريخ
وبالتالي هذه المصلحه الاسرائيليه هذا
بالاضافه الى ما يحصل داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي من انقسام هو ليس فقط مرتبط
بما يحصل في المناطق المحتله في يعني هناك
كان هناك تصريح على ان المجموعات المسلحه
والميليشيات
المستوطنين هي من يقوم عمليا بالقرار
السياسي والامني فيما يحصل في المناطق
المحتله وهذا ما لا تريده القياده الامنيه
شكرا جزيلا لك من الناصره محمد زيدان
الباحث المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه في شان فلسطيني اخر افادت
مصادر محليه فلسطينيه باندلاع اشتباكات
مسلحه بين مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات امنيه
تابعه للسلطه الفلسطينيه في مخيم جنين
وقالت وسائل اعلام ان مخيم جنين شهد
انتشارا للاجهزه الامنيه التابعه للسلطه
تزامنا مع مسير عسكري لكتيبه جنين في ذكرى
انطلاقه حركه الجهاد الاسلامي فيما قالت
مصادر محليه ان مسلحين اطلقوا النار
باتجاه مقاطعه جنين مما ادى الى اشتباكات
بين الجانبين واقفين عن سوبر ماركت الزهه
تقريبا وكانت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي قد
اتهمت اجهزه امن السلطه الفلسطينيه
باقتحام المهرجان الذي اقامته وسط مخيم
نور شمس في مدينه طولكرم بالضفه الغربيه
بمناسبه الذكر ال 36 لانطلاق الحركه وقال
المكتب الاعلامي للحركه ان عناصر من
الاجهزه الامنيه الفلسطينيه اعتدت على
المشاركين واطلقوا قنابل الغاز المسي
الدموع والرصاص
الحي وقد دع الامين العام لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي زياد النخاله السلطه الفلسطينيه
الى الافراج عن جميع المعتقلين السياسيين
والمقاومين جاء ذلك في تصريحات للنخاله في
ذكرى انطلاق حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي ادعو السلطه
الفلسطينيه الى الافراج عن عن كل
المعتقلين السياسيين
والمقاومين والتي
بسببهم افشلت لقاء الامناء
العامين من رام الله معنا محمد هواش
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي استاذ محمد اهلا
وسهلا بك يعني ما مبرر هذه الاقتحامات
بالنسبه للسلطه الفلسطينيه في هذا
التوقيت
مساء الخير لك وساده المشاهدين
والمتابعين اعتقد بان السلطه الفلسطينيه
تحاول يعني عدم اعطاء انطباع بان
الفلسطينيين يقومون ب مسيرات مسلحه خارج
اطار السلطه الوطنيه و خارج اجماع الاجماع
الوطني الفلسطيني وهي لا تستهدف المقاومين
على الاطلاق بالرصاص الحي وايضا المقاومون
لا يستهدفون السلطه الفلسطينيه وافراد
الاجهزه الامنيه بالرصاص الحي هناك
محاولات لتفريق التظاهرات العسكريه
والمظاهر
العسكريه التي يعني رافقت احتفالات حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي بذكراها سيد محمد سيد
محمد هناك صور لاطلاق نار وتم فض احتفال
لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي نعم نعم انا انا يعني اقول بانه
هناك حدثت يعني اشتباكات وليس بمعنى
بالمعنى العسكري اشتباكات عسكريه هناك
محاولات لفض
هذه التجمعات العسكريه لحركه الجهاد وا
يعني الاكتفاء
ب يعني الاحتفاء بهذه المناسبه بصوره
سياسيه وبصوره جماهيريه وليس بصوره مسلحه
تعطي انطباعا اخر عن السلطه الفلسطينيه
وعن الوضع الفلسطيني الداخلي لا حتى حتى
في هذه الاشتباكات التي جرت اليوم لم يطلق
يعني الفلسطينيون الرصاص على بعضهم اطلقوا
الرصاص في الهواء لتفريق هذه التظاهر ول
يعني وضع حد ل يعني الاشكال غير مناسبه من
وجهد نظر السلطه الفلسطينيه لهذه ما رايك
في ما يقوله يعني ما قاله مسؤول في الجهاد
الاسلامي من ان هذا على حد وصفه قرار
امريكي
اسرائيلي لا ليس قرارا امريكيا ولا قرارا
اسرائيليا هو قرار فلسطيني تريد السلطه
الفلسطينيه ان ان تكون المقاومه مقاومه
حقيقيه ولا وان تبتعد عن يعني
التظاهر المسلح في الاماكن العامه وان لا
تعطي اسرائيل ذرائع لاقتحامات والمزيد من
الاقتحامات
للمخيمات والقرى الفلسطينيه كما حصل
بالامس في في في مدينه بلده حواره وفي
طرمس عيا وفي عدد من القرى والبلدات
الفلسطينيه التي يقتحمها والمستوطنون
بحمايه الجيش الاسرائيلي ل يعني اجبار
الفلسطينيين على ايه ايه يعني الركوع
والاستسلام و ومنع مقاومتهم الفلسطينيون
يقاومون اسرائيل بكل الاشكال السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه والعسكريه وهي اشكال كلها
تكامليه وليست تنافسيه على الاطلاق ولا
يوجد مشكلات في ان تكون هناك يعني مقاومه
فلسطينيه مسلحه ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وضد مستوطنين وان تكون هناك حركه سياسيه
ودبلوماسيه
لوقف يعني الاجتياحات الاسرائيليه للمناطق
الفلسطينيه ووقف كل الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه لحقوق الفلسطينيين من القدس
الى الى الى جينين الى طول كرم الى الى
رام الله الى كل المدن الفسيه التي يستبح
الجيش الاسرائيلي والمستوطنون شكرا جز
شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله محمد هواش
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وينضم الينا عبر
الهاتف محمد الهندي نائب الامين العام
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي سيد محمد يعني ما
مبرر ان يكون هناك هذا التوتر الفلسطيني
الفلسطيني في هذا الوقت الذي نشهد فيه
تصعيدا
اسرائيليا يعني
اولا ليس هناك مبرر لاي توتر دخلي فلسطيني
لكن
اي الذي حدث ان هناك اعتداء على ام على
امهات الشهداء الذاهبين من جنين للمشاركه
في الانطلاقه في مخيم ش نور
شمس
الحقيقه يعني
بدون تجميل
للصوره الاعتداء هذا الاعتداء نحن ندقق
فيه لكن هذا الاعتداء يعتبر اكثر الاعمال
خزيا تحت مسمى التنسيق الامني اسرائيل
تقتحم المناطق الف
تذهب القوات العدو الى اي مكان تريده تمنع
كل شيء اعتقل الان القدس الجميع يرى ما
تفعله اسرائيل على مدار ست ايام في المسجد
الاقصى الاقتحامات
المستوطنون بدل ان يكون هذا جرس
انذار ما ان يلوح العدو باي كلام تسارع
السلطه لتقول اننا نقوم بالتنسيق الاان
اليس الا يوجد بينكم وبين السلطه يعني
تواصل على مستويات عليا لحل امور من هذا
النوع
هو الحقيقه على الميدان على الارض للاسف
هناك اتصالات لكن للاسف الميدان على الارض
ما نراه من فيديوهات منشوره هي يعني
ليست على مسير عسكري كما يظن البعض هو على
اهالي على الناس حتى لو كان مسير عسكري
لماذا لا
تستعرض يستعرض الفلسطيني قدراته على
المقاومه المقاومه هي الامل المقاومه
تتحول كان الى حاله عامه والى حاله شعبيه
المقاومه هي الجدار الاخير للامه امام
الانهيار
الموجود هي الامل للفلسطيني طالما انه ليس
مسيرا عسكريا تقول اعتداء على اهالي في
رايك ما الذي يمكن ان يكونوا ان يكون
منطقيا في اعتداء على امهات الشهداء كما
تقول لماذا تتى السلطه ان تفعل امرا كهذا
غير مقبول نهائيا انا اقول لك هذا اكثر
الاعمال خزيا في التاريخ
الطه اذا كان مقبولا ام لا سؤالي اصلا ما
هو المنطق في ان تقوم السلطه بهذا ليس ليس
هناك اي منطق انا اقول لك تريد ان تثبت
انها لازالت شريكا تثبت لامريكا تثبت
لاسرائيل انها لازالت شريكا في اي عمليه
سياسيه هل هناك عمليه سياسيه الان هناك
تطبيع وهناك اعتداءات على الاقصى وهناك
استيطان مستمر وهناك اعتداء على شعبنا في
كل مكان واقتحامات يوميه واعتقالات يوميه
اين كانت هذه الرصاصات عندما كانت اسرائيل
تجتاح مناطق السلطه
الفلسطينيه السلطه الفلسطينيه يجب ان
تحاسب كل من اطلق رصاصه على الذين ذهبوا
ليحتفلوا بانطلاقه الجهاد الاسلامي الجهاد
الاسلامي اليوم ليس له اي منافسه لا في
سلطه ولا في غير سلطه الجهاد الاسلامي قال
كلمه واحده منذ سنوات طويله ان هذا السلاح
الذي بايدي المجاهدين مصو نحو صدرر العدو
فقط واثبت على مدار سنوات طويله الا انه
لم يطلق رصاصه واحده في اتجاه السلطه
الفلسطينيه ويعرف ان هذه السلطه يعني لا
قيمه لها في اي مشروع يخدم الشعب
الفلسطيني ويحقق انجازات ومع ذلك هو حافظ
على سلاحه في اتجاه واحد الان عندما تذهب
الجهاد الاسلامي من اجل ان تقيم احتفال
بطلاتها بعد هذه الدماء وهذه الشهداء وهذه
الطبيات الكبيره ياتي من يريد ان يمنعها
محجه انه خارج الاجماع الوطني الاجماع
الوطني مع المقاومه اليوم الشعب الفلسطيني
كله مع المقاومه يتحدث البعض عن تجمعات
عسكريه هذا هراء هذا كلام يعني فارغ ليس
له اي قيمه ان شكرا جزيلا شكرا جزيلا لك
محمد الهندي نائب الامين العام لحركه
الجهاد
[موسيقى]
الاسلامي قالت وزاره الدفاع التركيه ان
قواتها نفذت ضربات جويه ضد اهداف لمسلحي
حزب العمال الكردستاني في شمالي سوريا
واضافت الوزاره ان غارات قواتها ان هذه
الغارات للقوات الجويه دمرت 15 هدفا بما
في ذلك مستودعات ومخابئ لمسلحي حزب
العمال من جانبها افادت الخارجيه
الامريكيه بان واشنطن وانقره شددتا على
هدفهما المشترك بالقضاء على التهديدات
الارهابيه وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
انشطه الارهابيه تقوض امن الولايات
المتحده وتركيا والحلفاء بغض النظر عن
مكانها سواء في سوريا او العراق او اي
مكان اخر واضاف بيان الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان الوزير انتوني بلينكن اكد على ضروره
التنسيق بين تركيا والولايات
المتحده وكانت وزاره الخارجيه قالت في
بيان لها ان الوزير هاكان فيدان اكد في
اتصال هاتفي مع نظيره الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن اكد وزير الخارجيه التركي حسب
البيان على ضروره تخلي واشنطن عن العمل مع
وحدات حمايه الشعب التي وصفها بالمنظمه
الارهابيه في شمالي سوريا واضاف البيان ان
فيدان شدد على استمرار تركيا بكل حزم في
عملياتها في اطار مكافحه الارهاب في كل من
العراق و
سوريا معنا من انقره مراسله الجزيره فرح
الزمان الشوقي فرح اذا لعلك تطلعين على
تفاصيل
اكثر
نعم عثمان في البيان الاخير الصادر عن
وزاره الدفاع التركيه نتحدث هنا عن ضربه
جديده يتم فيها استهداف حوالي 15 هدفا
والمزيد من عمليات التحييد على حد وصف
وزاره الدفاع التركيه الى جانب استهداف
بعض المواقع وما يوصف هنا بانها مخابئ
لقاده في حزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه هذه الضربات تاتي ضمن
سلسله ضربات تشنها انقره على شمال سوريا
وحتى على شمال العراق ردا على الهجوم الذي
وقع في العاصمه التركيه يوم الاحد الماضي
ولكن من الواضح في الحقيقه عثمان تكثيف
مستوى العمليات على المحور السوري خلال
اليوم وايضا خلال ليل امس يوم امس جرى
الحديث عن استهداف 30 نقطه في شمال سوريا
واليوم ايضا المواقع التابعه للجهات
الرسميه التركيه وحتى وسائل الاعلام
التركيه كانت تبث صور مباشره ل المواقع
التي استهدفتها القوات التركيه وتقول
بانها ابار ل النفط في مناطق يسيطر عليه
او تسيطر عليها الوحدات الكرديه ومن هذا
الباب اطلقت تركيا تحذيرها مجددا لمن
تصفهم بالاطراف الثالثه والاصدقاء
للابتعاد عن هذه النقاط تحديدا ايه لذا
اليوم تقول وزاره الدفاع التركيه بانها
استخدمت طائرات او مقاتلات اف 16 وضربت
على عمق 50 ك داخل الحدود السوريه الى
جانب ضربات اخرى نفذتها
بالمسيرات
وب الذخائر
الموجهه ويجري الحديث اليوم عن استهداف
المناطق الخاصه بابار
ومواقع نفطيه للمواقع المحسوبه على
الوحدات الكرديه و حزب العمال الكردستاني
كل هذا ياتي بعد تطورات وقعت يوم امس كذلك
حيث تم استهداف عسكريين اتراك وجرى الحديث
بحسب المواقع التركيه عن اصابه ثمانيه
اشخاص خمسه منهم من القوات الخاصه وثلاثه
من الجنود الاتراك لا يوجد حديث عن سقوط
قتلى بين
العسكريين الاتراك وتركيا من جهتها تتهم
الوحدات الكرديه التي تصنفها بالارهابي
على المستوى السياسي عثمان لعل اهم
الاتصالات التي جرت اليوم هي تلك التي جرت
بين وزيري الخارجيه التركي والامريكي لا
سيما بعد تاكيد تركيا على مساله اسقاط
المسيره
التركيه والتي تحدثت فيها تركيا برساله
تصعيديه احيانا ودبلوماسيه في احيان اخرى
تصعيديه حين دعت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى الكف عن دعم الوحدات
الكرديه باعتبارها تهديد للامن القومي
التركي وتهدد حلفا في النيتو على حد وصف
انقره ووجهت رسائل دبلوماسيه من ناحيه
ثانيه كون انقره غير معنيه باشتباك مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ودعت الى
تفعيل ما تصفه باليه التصعيد بما يمنع هذا
الاشتباك لكن بالنتيجه عثمان تركيا واضح
بانها ستستمر بهذه العمليات وهو ما اكده
على كل الاحوال وزير الخارجيه التركي
لنظيره الامريكي من انقره فرح زمان شوقي
شكرا جزيلا لك فرح
وترافق ذلك مع تطورات ميدانيه حيث تهدد
التطورات الميدانيه في الشمال السوري
بتقويض حاله الهدوء النسبي التي سادت
المنطقه منذ التوصل الى اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار في مارس 2020 لا سما في ظل تصعيد
النظام لهجماته الصاروخيه على مناطق
المعارضه المسلحه واستمرار تركيا في
حملتها العسكريه ضد التنظيمات الكرديه في
مناطق الدراع
الفرات منذ نحو ثلاث سنوات ونصف تشهد
مناطق الشمال السوري حاله من الهدوء
النسبي مهد لها اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
الذي تم التوصل اليه عبر تفاهمات تركيه
روسيه
ايرانيه لكن تلك الاتفاقات تبدو اليوم
امام امتحان صعب في ظل عوده الغارات
والضربات الصاروخيه والمدفعيه المكثفه الى
المنطقه فللي الثاني على التوالي تواصل
قوات النظام قصف بلدات وقرى في ريفي ادلب
وحلب ما اوقع قتل وجرحى بينهم نساء واطفال
وبحسب الدفاع المدني التابع للمعارضه فان
الهجمات استهدفت اسواق شعبيه واحياء سكنيه
ومدارس ومسجدا ومركزا للدفاع المدني ومحطه
محروقات تصعيد النظام كان قد بدا بعد
ساعات من هجوم هو الاكبر على قواته منذ
سنوات حين استهدفت مسيرات مجهوله حفل
تخريج لطلاب الكليه الحربيه في مدينه حمص
ما اوقع بحسب احدث حصيله نحو 90 قتيلا
واكثر من 270 جريحا النظام السوري اتهم ما
وصفها بالتنظيمات الارهابيه المسلحه
المدعومه من اطراف دوليه معروفه
بالمسؤوليه عن هجوم حمص واكد انه سيرد
عليها بكل قوه وحزم في حين اكد الكرملين
ان موسكو تعتزم مواصله العمل مع الشركاء
السوريين لمكافحه ما سماه الارهاب ما ترجم
سريعا بغارات روسيه استهدفت جسر الشغور
بالتوازي مع هذه التطورات تواصل تركيا
احدى الاطراف الضامنه لاتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار في الشمال السوري غاراتها وقصفها
على مواقع تابعه لحزب العمال الكردستاني
ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه التي تصاعدت
منذ الهجوم الذي استهدف مديريه الامن في
انقره مطلع الشهر الجاري وتبناه التنظيم
الكردي اذ قالت وزاره الدفاع التركيه ان
26 عنصرا من حزب العمال الكردستاني قتلوا
في قصف لمواقع الحزب في منطقه درع الفرات
في شمالي سوريا واشارت الوزاره الى ان
القصف جاء ردا على ما وصفتها بعمليه
ارهابيه للحزب استهدفت قاعده عسكريه تركيه
في منطقه دابق في ريف حلب الشرقي ما اوقع
عددا من الجرحى في صفوف قواتها وفي السياق
ذاته قالت الخارجيه التركيه في بيان لها
ان وزير الخارجيه هاكان فيدان اكد في
اتصال هات في مع نظيره الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن على ضروره تخلي الولايات المتحده
عن العمل مع وحدات حمايه الشعب التي وصفها
بالمنظمه الارهابيه في شمال سوريا من
جانبها قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان واشنطن
وانقره شددتا على هدفهم المشترك بالقضاء
على التهديدات الارهابيه التي تقوض امن
الولايات المتحده وتركيا بغض النظر عن
المكان الذي تنطلق منه وان الوزير بلينكن
اكد لنظيره التركي ضروره تنسيق انشطه
البلدين معنا من باريس الدكتور زياد ماجد
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
الامريكيه في باريس دكتور هل يمكن ان تشرح
لنا ما
يحدث يعني من الصعب ربما الاحاطه بجوانب
كل ما يحدث لكن هناك بلا شك وكما ذكر في
تقريركم مرحله تتبدل فيها التفاهمات التي
كانت سائده والتي ادت الى نوع من الهدوء
الذي كانت تتخلله بين الوقت والاخر عمليات
قصف يشنها النظام وحليفه الروسي لكن بشكل
عام كان التفاهم الايراني التركي الروسي
يضمن نوعا من ال الاستكانه في العمليات
العسكريه في الشمال الغربي السوري وكان
هناك ايضا ضمانات امريكيه وتفاهمات مع
تركيا فيما خص المساله الكرديه وتجميد
البحث بها بانتظار تطورات اق قميه مختلفه
انما نرى الان بين الانتفاضه الشعبيه
المتجدده والمستمره بشجاعه في السويداء
بين اشتباكات جرت في شرق
سوريا ادمت فيها الميليشيات الكرديه
بميليشيات من عشائر عربيه ثم الصدام
التركي الكردي في الشمال والان بعد عمليه
حمص عوده القصف العنيف من قبل النظام
وروسيا الى على منطقه ادلب ربما نكون امام
مرحله تفاهمات جديده يحاول كل طرف فيها
تحسين بعض المواقع ليس العسكريه وانما
التفاوضيه السياسيه بانتظار جلاء امور على
علاقه بملف ايران مع امريكا بالحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه ارتبط الموضوع السوري
الان بمجمل تطورات تخرج عن الاطار الوطني
الان يعني انا في بدايه في
بدايه سؤالي طلبت منك ان تشرح ما يحدث
الان اسالك ان تشرح لنا ما قلته للتو يعني
اين هي المشكله لماذا تتبدل هذه التفاهمات
هل هذا قرار سوري له علاقه بما يحدث في
السويداء وغيرها ام ام قرار خارجي له
علاقه تحسين ظروف تفاوضيه في ملفات ربما
اكبر كما ذكرت من روسيا و ولا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لماذا تتبدل هذه الم
التفاهمات
والى
ماذا نعم لا طبعا انا ما قصدته هو ان
الموضوع يخرج عن اطار القرار السوري هناك
الان من الجهه الامريكيه وبعد مفاوضات جرت
مع ايران من دون الوصول الى نتيجه حتى
الان اعاده تموضع امريكي كانت واضحه فيما
يخص مراق مراقبه الحدود مع العراق
واستمرار التاكيد على ان لا خروج امريكي
من سوريا كما كان يقال سابقا ايه في
الموضوع التركي الكردي التصعيد يدل على ان
تركيا لم تعد راضيه عن الستاتيكو او عن
الاتفاقات التي كانت قائمه سابقا بضمانات
امريكيه وبوسط روسيه خاصه بعد العمليه
التي وقعت في انقره وايضا من جهه الانفجار
الذي حصل في حمص والذي ما زال غامضا لان
طريق المسيرات من ادلب طويل ويمكن ان يرصد
من قبل اجهزه الدفاع الروسيه والسوريه لان
القد القدره التفجيريه كانت مرتفعه جدا
هناك الكثير من الغموض الذي يحيط به انما
التصعيد الذي تلاه يدل ايضا على ان وقف
اطلاق النار في منطقه ادلب لم يعد مضمونا
كما كان من قبل وربما يكون هناك جوله
تفاوض جديده روسيا
امريكيه عفوا روسيا تركيا ايرانيه من
ناحيه كما في السابق لاعاده الوصول الى
تفاهمات وايضا تركيا امريكيه في م خص
المساله الكرديه وهذا كله يدل عن الاطار
الوطني للصراع السوري انتهى منذ فتره
والقرارات تؤخذ في الخارج وترتبط بموازين
قوى وببحث من اطراف الخارج عن رسائل
يستخدم تستخدم الارض السوريه كمساحه لها
وهذا لا ينفي بالطبع ان مساله السويداء
تبقى مساله سوريه خاصه باهل المنطقه
وبشجاعة
الخارجيه المذكوره شكرا جزيلا للدكتور
زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه الامريكيه في باريس
[موسيقى]
شك قالت وسائل اعلام روسيه ان الجيش
الروسي بدا هجوما على مواقع للجيش
الاوكراني في محور كوبيانسك في مقاطعه
خاركيف واضافت المصادر ان القوات الروسيه
تقدمت في بعض الخطوط على الجهه الشماليه
الشرقيه من مدينه كوبيانسك تحت قصف مدفعي
وجوي كثيف في غضون ذلك اعرب الاتحاد
الاوروبي عن قلقه الشديد ازاء خطط روسيا
لانشاء قاعده بحريه دائمه لاسطوره في
البحر الاسود في منطقه ابخازيا الانفصاليه
في جورجيا واعتبر ان الوجود العسكريه
الروسيه في المنطقه غير قانوني وينتهك
سياده جورجيا وسلامه
اراضيها هجوم روسي جديد على خاركيف ثاني
اكبر المدن الاوكرانيه روسيا جددت قص
المنطقه باستخدام صاروخين من طراز اسكندر
في الهجوم الذي اسقط عشرات الجرحى والحق
اضرارا ببنى تحتيه في المدينه وانتشلت جثه
طفل من تحت انقاض المباني المدمره يتزامن
ذلك مع اعلان روسيا الهجوم على مواقع
للجيش الاوكراني في محور جوبيان السك
بمقاطعه خاركيف وان القوات الروسيه تتقدم
في المحور وفي بعض الخطوط على الجبهه
الشماليه الشرقيه من خاركيف وان الجيش
الاكر
تكبد خسائر كبيره وكانت هجمات صاروخيه
روسيه يوم الخميس قد اسفرت عن مصرع
العشرات في قريت روزا شمال شرق اوكرانيا
في هجوم وصف بانه احد اسوا الهجمات
الفرديه من حيث عدد الضحايا منذ بدء حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا في فبراير العام
الماضي الرئيس الاوكراني فلودمير زيلينسكي
وصف الهجمات الروسيه وما احدثته من خسائر
وسط المدنيين بانه ارهاب روسي يتعين على
اوكرانيا الصمود في وجهه كما وجدت الهجمات
ادانه اوروبيه واسعه ولفتت الانظار الى ما
يمكن ان تسفر عنه تطورات الاحداث خاصه في
ظل توقع مفوض السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي تخصيص خمسه مليارات يورو
كمساعدات عسكريه لاوكرانيا للعام القادم
كما ستقدم المفوضيه الاوروبيه في الخريف
توصياتها لفتح مفاوضات انضمام اوكرانيا
ومولدافيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي في هذه
الاثناء اثار اعلان رئيس ابخازيا
الانفصاليه اصلان بجانا ان روسيا ستنشئ
قريبا قاعده عسكريه في ابخازيا للاسطول
البحر الروسي اثار قلق الاتحاد الاوروبي
ويظل الثابت في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وتداعياتها في ظل الواقع الراهن ومؤشراته
هو الاتجاه نحو التصعيد العسكري وبينما
يخفق الطرفان في تحقيق تغييرات كبيره على
الارض تظل كل الاسئله مطروحه بشان صراع
الاستراتيجيات ونتائجها في
المنطقه نقلت صحيفه بوليتيكو عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان اداره الرئيس جو بايدن
تدرس استخدام برنامج المنح التابع
للخارجيه لارسال مساعدات عسكريه اضافيه
الى اوكرانيا وقالت الصحيفه ان البيت
الابيض يدرس مجموعه خيارات في اطار مساعيه
للعثور على ام اضافيه لدعم كيف بعد
استثناء الكونجرس اوكرانيا من التمويل
المؤقت وكان الاتحاد الاوروبي قد حذر في
وقت سابق من انه لن يكون قادرا على سد اي
فجوه تمويل لدعم اوكرانيا قد تتركها
الولايات المتحده بشكل
كامل ملف التحرك الروسي في البحر الاسود
والحديث عن القاعده العسكريه الجديده في
ابخازيا سيكون نقطه متابعه تفصيليه بعد
قليل ضمن فقره في
[موسيقى]
المتابعه قال وزير الدوله في الخارجيه
القطريه محمد بن عبد العزيز الخليفي ان
قطر ملتزمه بلعب دور في الوساطه بشان
برنامج ايران النووي واضاف الخليفي في
مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ان ان هذه الوساطه
ليست امرا سهلا
ق قطر في اطار سياستها الخارجيه تؤمن بقوه
بالمشاركه بفعاليه في صنع السلام في
منطقتنا وعلى المستوى الدولي وتضع دول عده
ثقتها فينا للعب دور في الوساطه بين ايران
وبين العديد من الدول الاخرى بما في ذلك
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي فيما يتعلق
بالمحادثات النوويه هذا الموضوع ليس امرا
سهلا ونحن ملتزمون بلعب هذا الدور ومحاوله
ايجاد ارضيه مشتركه بدعم من المنسق
الاوروبي
المحدد ولدى سؤاله عن العقبات التي
واجهتها قطر بشان الوساطه في ملف تبادل
السجناء بين الولايات المتحده وايران
الشهر الماضي قال وزير الدوله في الخارجيه
القطريه محمد بن عبد العزيز الخليفي ان
الدوحه تشعر بالسعاده لانها تمكنت من
انجاز الوساطه رغم صعوبه
ذلك لم يكن الامر سهلا كانت هناك عده
رحلات وتنقلات من فندق لاخر لكن فرقنا في
الدوحه تمكنت من ايصال الرساله بوضوح الى
الاطراف ومن جعلهم اقرب الى الاتفاق ومن
دواعي سرورنا اننا تمكنا من القيام
وارجع وزير الدوله في الخارجيه القطريه
سبب اكتساب بلاده ثقه لدى الدول الاخرى في
حل النزاعات الى سجل الدوحه في الوساطه
بين
الدول دور الوساطه ليس منهجا جديدا
بالنسبه لقطر فنحن نمتلك خبره طويله
للغايه في هذا المجال تمتد على مدى 5 عاما
شاركنا في العديد من الوساطات الناجحه في
الصومالي وكينيا وتشاد افغانستان وفلسطين
ولبنان وغيرها وقطر اكتسبت ثقه لدى الدول
للعب دور في حل النزاعات بسبب سجلها في
الوساطه وفيما يتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
قال وزير الدوله في الخارجيه القطريه ان
اي اتفاقيه محتمله يجب ان تتضمن حلا لحقوق
الفلسطينيين انها احدى اهم المواضيع
الاساسيه بالنسبه لنا في الشرق الاوسط
موقفنا واضح للغايه ازاءها وهو انه يجب
منح الفلسطينيين حقوقهم حقوقهم في الحريه
وحقوقهم في الارض واعتقد ان هذه الامور
يجب حلها باي طريقه ممكنه في اي اتفاقيه
[موسيقى]
محتمله كشف برنامج المتحري جزءا من قضيه
صادمه ومعقده عمرها سبعه عقود تتعلق
باختفاء الاف من اطفال اليهود اليمنيين
بعد وصولهم الى اسرائيل والتجار بهم مقابل
التبني مع من عائلات يهوديه غربيه استغرق
التحقيق الاستقصائي نحو عامين قبل الوصول
الى باحثين وافراد من عائلات ضحايا
الاختطاف الممنهج الذي ترفض السلطات
الاسرائيليه الاعتراف بحدوثه او الاعتذار
عنه من بساط الريح الى بساط التيه اين
اختفى الاف اطفال اليهود اليمنيين ولماذا
تص ر الحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه على
طمس الحقائق حتى بعد مرور 70 عاما عمان من
البحث والتقصي هي المده التي استغرقها
فريق برنامج التحري لنفض الغبار ولو جزئيا
على قضيه كشف ملابساتها يظهر مره اخرى
للعالم عنصريه الدوله العبريه والخطط
الممنهجه لاختطاف وتفريق اطفال عن
عائلاتهم الاصليه من رحم تجارب خاصه الف
بعض اقارب الا الاطفال الذين لم يعودوا
الى ذويهم كتبا واجريت بحوث اكاديميه
شوشانا مدمونه واحده
منهم بعد تاسيس الدوله في عام
1948 وحتى عام
1949 نقلت الدوله جوا نحو 50 ال من اليهود
اليمنيين من اليمن وبما انه تم اسكانهم في
اماكن مختلفه من البلاد في مخيمات مسقوفه
من الصفيح قيل لهم سيكون من الافضل
للاطفال لو اخذوا الى مساكن الاطفال
المبنيه من
الحجر بعد وقت قصير تبلغ سلطات المستشفى
الاهالي بوفاه الطفل دون تسليم الجثه او
اصدار شهاده وفاه لا عزاء ولا قبر لانهم
ببساطه ضحايا عمليه ممنهجه للاتجار باطفال
يهود يمنيين لانهم وفق بعض المعتقدات
اليهوديه قد يكونون اكثر نقاء من غيرهم ول
خمسه اجيال لم يكن هناك زواج خارج الطائفه
في اليمن وبالتالي نسلهم هو الافضل للتبني
من قبل اسر يهوديه
غربيه بلغت ظاهره الاختفاء ذروتها عام
1950 ولدينا شهادات في موقعنا تقدر عدد
المختفين بنحو الف
طفل واعتقد ان الدكتور ناثان فرس قدر في
كتاب له حول القضيه عدد المخفين بنحو ال
طفل ونحن يعتقد ان هناك حالات لم تصلنا
وبالتالي الحديث عن بضعه الاف من الاطفال
لم يكن يسيرا الوصول الى عائلات المفقودين
او المختطفين او من تم الاتجار بهم وبعضهم
اعتذر في اللحظات الاخيره عن مقابله فريق
البرنامج بسبب تعرضهم لضغوط وتهديدات
خارجيه لكن باتيا اسحاقي قبلت الحديث عن
ماساه عائلتها وجد اهلها سرير شقيقتها
رحيل ذات اليه 20 يوما فارغا وابلغ انها
ماتت كالعاده لا جثه ولا شهاده
وفاه امي وابي حتى مماتهما كانا يفكران
دوما انهما سيلتقيان بها كان على امل
لرؤيتها حتى اللحظه الاخيره لكن لم يتحقق
لهما
[موسيقى]
ذلك بعد احتجاجات كثيره شكلت ثلاث لجان
تحقيق داخل اسرائيل في فترات زمنيه مختلفه
للاجابه عن سؤال يسمع منذ سبعه عقود اين
ذهب اطفال يهود اليمن الذين اختفوا من
المستشفيات وفي كل مره كانت يد خفيه تعبث
بالتقارير وبنتائج اما بتزييف الحقائق او
بحرق بعض الملفات لتضيع الحقيقه اكثر
ومعها تستبعد شبهه الجريمه الممنهجه التي
نف نفذتها دوله نجح فريق البرنامج في
الوصول الى وثائق خاصه بالارشيف
الاسرائيلي وايضا توثيق التصريحات مهمه
لاعضاء داخل الكنيست اجمعوا على ان
السلطات الاسرائيليه ضللت المجتمع وبان
لجان التحقيق لم تكن يوما جاده في عملها
لو عرف العالم حجم العنصريه السائده داخل
مجتمع اليهود لن تحظى اسرائيل بذلك القدر
الكبير من التعاطف خصوصا من المجتمع
اليهودي الغربي
عاشت وماتت الاف الاسر اليمنيه التي نقلت
الى اسرائيل دون ان تعرف مصير ابن او بنت
ضحايا جريمه ترفض السلطات تلبي بالاعتراف
بها والاعتذار عنها لتبقى القضيه وصمه عار
اخر في تاريخها الحافل
بالانتهاكات معنا من لندن الدكتور جيمس
ايد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه كوين
ميري سيد ايد شاهدت الفيلم فما الذي اضافه
الى ما
تعرفه
كباحث اعتقد انه من الواضح والجلي
ان اننا نتعامل مع قصه لم يتم التحقيق
فيها بالشكل المناسب من قبل الدوله او من
قبل الحكم الاسرائيلي اكثر من 70 عاما
والان بدانا نكشف او نعت او نجد ان هنالك
المزيد من القصص التي لم تروى وكثير من
الشهادات التي باتت تتداول وان هنك كثير
من الاسئله التي ما زالت البحث جار على
اجابات عنها هل هذه قضيه عنصريه بشكل واضح
عندما يؤخذ 1500 طفل من يهود يمنيين ليتب
اناهم يهود غربيون لماذا يمكن ان ان يفعل
امر من هذا النوع اخذ كل هذا العدد الكبير
من الاطفال من اس من اسرهم
اعتقد ان ان هنالك مساله عنصريه او بعدا
عنصريا لهذه المساله سيموا ان الغالبيه
العظمى من هؤلاء الاطفال هم من دول شرق
اوسطيه وعلى وجه التحديد اليمن وراينا في
الفيلم
الوثائقي ان هنالك من كان مسؤولا عن هذه
المساله حيث انهم ينظرون ينظرون الى
اليمنيين انهم ذو سلاله نقيه ولكن لا
يستحقون ان يعيشوا في كنف عائلاتهم وكان
من الواضح من الناحيه الايديولوجيه التي
كانت سائده انذاك انه من الافضل بالنسبه
لهؤلاء الاطفال ان ينشا وترعرعوا مع يهود
من يهود اوروبيين فهذا سيكون افضل لهم الى
اي مدى ينظر الى المجتمع الاسرائيلي على
انه مجتمع عنصري بوضوح مع كل المشاكل
الموجوده مع الفلسطينيين وما اشتكى منهم
منه يهود
فلاشه اثيوبي ويهود شرقيون وهذه القضيه
قضيه الاطفال اليمنيين الى اي مدى يوضح
هذا ان هذا مجتمع بالفعل عنصري الى حد
بعيد اعيد اعيد السؤال سريعا اضافه الى ما
اشتكى منه يهود فلاشا اثيوبي ويهود شرقيون
والان هذه القضيه قضيه مئات الاطفال من
اليهود اليمنيين الى اي مدى هذا يبدي ان
هذا مجتمع عنصري بشكل كبير المجتمع
الاسرائيلي اعتقد ان هذا يظهر بوضوح
ان العنصريه هي مساله او مشكله بنيويه في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي منذ انشائه ومن غير
المصادفه انها مشكله بهذا الحجم تؤثر او
اثرت على يهود من اصول شرق او الصوتيه
واعتقد انه بشكل عام فان الانطباع المتعلق
بال
الاستعلاء
لهؤلاء على الشرق الاوسطين ربما يلعب
دورا في نزع هؤلاء الاطفال من
عائلاتهم وطبعا هذا له علاقه بالصوره
النمطيه التي ربما عبر عنها بعض المسؤولين
العائلات بحاجه الى
اجابات عن ما حدث لاطفالهم وتقاعس الحكومه
وتلقيها في اعطاء اجوبه يظهر بوضوح ان
هنالك مشكله تواجه اليهود من مناطق او من
دول غير اوروبيه دكتور جيمس اي استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه كوين ميري في
لندن شكرا جزيلا في السودان في ولايه ار
شرقي السودان كشفت السلطات الصحيه عن
اصابه اكثر من 700 شخص بحم ضنك النزفيه
كما حذرت من تفشي الامراض الوبائيه ومنها
الاسهالات المائيه وكثفت حملاتها لتحسين
الظروف البيئيه ومكافحه البعوض الناقل
لفيروس حما
الضنك رباب قابعه في منزلها بالقضارف
شرقيه
السودان مصابه بحم الضنك
ح خطيره والله ما عند اي علاج الا
المسكنات
البنادول و دريبات الجلكوز 17
دريب وما في اي تحسن تكسر في الجسم شديد
تجع رجول حم فظيعه وصداع فظيع والله منزل
رباب محاط بحشائش وبركه ماء وهي بيئه تؤدي
الى تكاثر الباعوض المعروف
بالاوس والذي يتسبب في حم الضنك النزفيه
وفقا للاحصاءات الرسميه تجاوز عدد
الاصابات 700 شخص بعضهم فارق الحياه ومن
المرجح يكون عدد المصابين اكثر لان بعضهم
يكتفي بفحوصات اوليه دون الذهاب الى
المستشفى لعدم توفر علاج للمرض هذا المرض
يصيب الانسان واخطر ماي ي ان يصل اليه هو
تكسر في الصفائح الدمويه مما يؤدي الى نسف
لذلك يصنف تبع الحميات
النسفيه معلومه مهمه انه هذا المرض يعني
يحتاج فقط للتدعيم ولزياده المناعه
الطبيعيه للانسان فلا يوجد عقار معين
لمعالجه هذا
المرض كثفت السلطات بولايه القضارف جهودها
لمكافحه البعوض الناقل للامراض الوبائيه
وتعهدت بتوفير كل ما يلزم للقضاء على هذه
الامراض الان اذا ما كان في تظافر بينه
وبين كل المواطنين وكل اللجان وكل الاحياء
وكل المناطق الحكايه دي الحكومه ما بتقدر
على اب الحكومه توفر المبيدات توفر
الطرمبات توفر الفنيين توفر العربات توفر
كل المطلوب من مال وغيره بعد ذاك لازم
يكون في مبادرات هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي تنتشر فيها حم الضنك بالقضارف
تحديات كبيره امام الحكومات المحليه في
مواجهه انتشار الامراض الوبائيه يزيدها
صعوبه ضعف الامكانات وارتفاع الكثافه
السكانيه بسبب النزوح الطاهر المرضي
الجزيره
القضارف نعود الى خبر اعتزام روسيا انشاء
قاعده بحريه في اقليم ابخازيا الانفصالي
في جورجيا القاعده العسكري ريه المزمع
ستكون على ساحر البحر الاسود لضمان امن
السفن الحربيه الروسيه عاقب تصاعد هجمات
اوكرانيا عليها في الفتره الاخيره لروسيا
ايضا قاعده اخرى في منطقه اوسيتيا
الجنوبيه
وسط جورجيا جنوب القوقاز وهي طبعا
انفصاليه وفي اوكرانيا المجاوره ضمت روسيا
عام 2014 شبه جزيره القرم الواقعه بين
البحر الاسود وبحر ازوف وتمت عمليه الضم
بعد استفتاء لم تعترف به كيف ولا الدول
الغربيه في سبتمبر 2022 اعلنت موسكو ضم
جمهوريتي دونيتسك ولوغانسك الانفصاليين في
شرق اوكرانيا على الحدود مع روسيا في حوض
نهر الدونتس في اليوم نفسه ضمت روسيا
منطقتين اخريين نتحدث في جنوب اوكرانيا
هما خيرسون وزبرو جيا على البحر الاسود
ونهر دنيبر وذلك عقب استفتاءات لم تحظى
بالاعتراف الدولي كما تهيمن روسيا على
اقليمين انفصاليين في مولدوفا المجاوره
وهما ما يسمى جمهوريه ترانسنيستريا بين
الدهر نهر د نتسر والحدود الاوكرانيه
اضافه الى اقليم جاكوزي الذي صدق برلمانه
المحلي عام 2014 على قانون الحمايه
المشتركه مع روسيا الاتحاديه بانتظار
استفتاء لتقرير المصير شكل الخريطه
الروسيه الذي تسعى موسكو لفرضه يبدو حتى
الان من جانب واحد ولا يحظى باي اعتراف
دولي والاهم ربما ان تلك التطلعات كثيرا
ما ارتبطت بالحروب والنزاعات المسلحه ومن
ابرزها الحرب على اوكرانيا الدائره منذ
فبراير
2022 فهي التي عجلت بفرض امر واقع على
اربع مناطق اوكرانيه شرقا وجنوبا قبل ذلك
دخلت حرب روسيا روسيا دخلت حربا مع جورجيا
عام 2008 ادت الى ترسيخ انفصال منطقتي
ابخازيا واوسيتيا الجنوبيه كما ان انفصال
اقليم ترانسنيستريا عن مولدوفا حصل بعد
تدخل الجيش الروسي الى جانب الانفصاليين
عام
1992 تكرر سيناريو عام
1994 عندما سندت القوات الروسيه انفصالي
اقليم جاكوزي في الحرب التي انتهت باعلان
استقلال الاقليم ينضم الينا من اوكسفورد
فرانك ليدوي وهو كبير الخبراء العسكريين
في مؤسسه جلوبس للدراسات سيد د دويج نيه
روسيا ان تنشئ قاعده عسكريه بح حريه في
ابخازيا ما الذي قد يعنيه لتوازنات القوى
في تلك
المنطقه ان هذا هو نتيجه تغير كبير رئيسي
في النشر البحري في البحر الاسود يوم امس
او اليوم الذي قبله يبدو ان البحريه
الروسيه اضطرت لانسحاب من سيفاستوبول وهي
قاعدتها البحريه الرئيسيه في شوف الجزيره
وهذا امر مهم جدا وكذلك على المستوى
الاستراتيجي وكما ذكرتم في مقدمت
الرائعه ابخازيا حيث [__] تبنا القاعده
الجديده يفترض انها
الوله لا تعترف بها الا روسيا
وهذا وهذا يقربها اكثر الى السيطره
الروسيه وربما قد نشد ضمها الى روسيا خلال
السنوات القادمه وكذلك المناطقه الاخرى
التي روسيا غير مستعده
لمها اي هل يمكن ان يكون
هناك اي قدرات بامكانها ان تعرقل هذه
النوايا
الروسيه لا اعتقد ذلك فهناك دعم قوي في
اغاس وجنوب ايستا لروسيا فالتعلم كان هناك
حروب جرت هناك لفتره طويله من الزمن وطبعا
سيكون هناك
الكثير من التعليقات
الخارجيه بالقول بان افخاز هي الواقع جزء
من جورجيا كما هو
جنوبيا التي فعلا جزء من جورجيا والتي
ستعترض بالتاكيد بقوه ولكن ليس ماكان
القوم باي شيء فروسيا هي المسيطره من
الناحيه العسكريه هل يمكن ان اتوقع اي رد
فعل
من دعنا نقول اعداء روسيا في مناطق
اخرى
طبعا ان العدو الرئيسي حاليا هم اوكرانيا
وبالتاكيد اوكرانيا لن تسمح بتحقيق ذلك
دون تدخل عسكري ولا لدي اي شك بان
جورجيا كما حالها الان لن تجد اي صعوبه في
ذلك وست توافق على هذا الامر ولن تدخل في
نزاع مع روسيا واو مع اوكرانيا الكثير من
الجورجيين الان يقاتلون الجانب
الاوكرانيين ولكن بشكل اكبر هذا يبين ان
هناك توسع مستمر تقوم به روسيا ونفوذ
روسيا في المنطقه وهذا
طبعا يكون متوازنا مع نسميه النصر
الاوكراني بازاحه البحريه الروسيه من
سيباستوبول
هناك من قد يقول ان هذا يثبت ان ان روسيا
في نهايه المطاف رغم كل الدعم الغربي ربما
لاوكرانيا تحقق
اهدافها ولكن هذا امر طبعا يخضع للكثير من
الجدول وقد يختلف معه
كثيرون ولهم اسبابهم ولكن لا يتسع الوقت
الحديث عن ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن
الدكتور جيمس ايستود استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه كين كوين ميري في
لندن بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد
الليله والان الى جوله منتصف الليل
وتتابعون مع عبد السلام وغن واليكم